el negocio prospera para las tiendas de
equipos militares en esta región de
Rusia los reservistas se pelean para
abastecerse mientras esperan ser
desplegados en Ucrania
apenas se anunció la movilización
parcial había montones de personas
compraron todo lo que había disponible
botas abrigos gorros para el frío todo
el equipamiento se agotó;
un reservista presente en la tienda dice
que el gobierno solo ha entregado ropa y
zapatos a los nuevos reclutas Ellos
están comprando el resto de su bolsillo
la gente compra sus propias linternas no
hay suficientes bolsas de dormir y
colchonetas para todo el mundo Antes
había muchas aquí en esta tienda ahora
no queda nada aquí ni en otros negocios
todo está agotado en todas partes
Incluso en tiendas de pesca y otras más
no hay guantes tácticos ni para el frío
el miércoles el New York Times publicó
llamadas interceptadas de soldados rusos
hablando a sus casas quedaban una
inusual visión de la moral de estas
tropas y lo que han visto en Ucrania
la mitad de nuestro regimiento se ha ido
nos dieron la orden de matar a todo el
que viéramos cuando llegué a casa
renunció al del ejército Putin es
un tonto quiere tomar pero no hay manera
de que hagamos eso los nuevos reclutas
están siendo enviados al frente de
batalla con poco o ningún entrenamiento
y hay temores de que el número de
convocados sea mucho más de 300.000
personas el jueves el presidente putina
admitió que ha habido algunos errores
dijo que los hombres con familias muy
grandes o los que están enfermos o
mayores deberían ser enviados de vuelta
a casa
es necesario investigar cada caso por
separado si se ha cometido un error
repito debe ser corregido es necesario
traer de regreso a los que fueron
seleccionados erróneamente
el llamado a movilización ha desatado
protestas en toda Rusia más de 2.400
personas han sido detenidas por ponerse
y alrededor de 200.000 han oído a países
vecinos